[Música]
alguna vez se han preguntado ustedes qué
voy a hacer de mi vida si tuviera o
hiciera esto sería feliz en algún
momento de mi vida cuando yo creía que
ya mi vida estaba resuelta y realizada
sentía un enorme vacío que no podía
entender ni explicar y me propuse ser
voluntaria de una institución cuya
misión principal es promover la salud
emocional en las personas en situación
de crisis
individual familiar o psicosocial claro
esto se logra con la ayuda que brindan
sus voluntarios a través de una escucha
activa y una orientación a todas
aquellas personas que están pasando por
una crisis y que acuden a la institución
a través de una llamada telefónica
al año aproximadamente
4000 personas son beneficiadas en las
diferentes áreas de esta institución
si nosotros multiplicamos esas 4000
personas por 4 como un promedio de
familia
concluimos que 16.000 personas se
benefician y cambian su estilo de vida
es así que a lo largo de muchos años yo
fui testigo de ver que más de 60 mil
personas
han logrado retomar el control de sus
vidas hacer un cambio de pensamiento y
sentimiento y tener el control
esto generó un aparte de eso yo me di
cuenta que cada uno de nosotros tiene la
capacidad de resolver y poder vivir con
calidad humana
esto generó en mí un gran impacto y
movió mi suelo y me detuve a pensar
qué puedo hacer y que me falta aún a el
título universitario con el que yo había
soñado
en honduras la población que accede a la
educación superior
está comprendida entre edades entre 18 y
25 años en su mayoría por supuesto yo
soy de la minoría
de esas personas solamente un 30% logran
obtener su título universitario ya que
los demás por una u otra situación
abandonan sus estudios
estos son datos tomados de la
universidad pedagógica en el año 2016
me di cuenta y aún podía hacer algo más
que la vida desde constante movimiento y
que los sueños y retos dormidos afloran
cuando nosotros tenemos una actitud
positiva
y que para lograrlos sólo basta
intentarlo una y otra vez
los sueños son una realidad en la medida
de lo posible si nosotros vamos tras
ellos
si no nos limitamos
si decidimos continuar y la manera de
lograrlo es intentándolo una y otra y
otra vez
por supuesto siempre vamos a encontrar
obstáculos en mi caso era la edad y no
faltaron personas
de buen corazón
con opiniones un poco
desalentadoras
como por ejemplo
ya estás vieja para qué vas a estudiar
si lo logras no te van a contratar en
una empresa
y bueno yo elegí terminar ese sueño
inconcluso que tenía y decidí terminar
mi carrera a mis 55 años
[Aplausos]
ya que los sueños son una realidad
posible en la medida que vayamos tras
ellos
porque los sueños no envejecen puede ser
que tú envejezca o que yo envejezca pero
nunca seré viejo
los sueños no envejecen
atrévete a emprender los ahora
[Aplausos]